what determines our intelligence
one school of thought is that okay maybe
you're either just born with it or you
either have it or you don't some people
are smart some people are less smart or
maybe you can change it and it turns out
there's actually been a lot of research
on this in the last few decades
and the answer is pretty clear that your
intelligence can actually be changed
what we've learned what researchers have
taught us is that our brains are
actually a lot like a muscle we know
that you can grow your muscles by going
into the gym and doing exercise and
straining your muscles you don't just
work on things that are easy for your
muscles to do you do things that your
muscles have to struggle with that your
muscles have to strain with and then
they rebuild themselves and they come
back stronger by struggling it's a it's
a signal to your body to devote more
resources to that part of the body and
we see that exact same thing with the
brain
and here are just a couple of examples
of it this first one this is
this is this shows how the human brain
develops in early childhood this is a a
depiction of of the the neurons in a
brain at birth and then over as a child
develops it it interacts with its
environment it tries things out it
struggles it struggles to to talk to
converse to interact with folks to
understand the world around it and as it
struggles you see that by age six you
have a much deeper and much stronger
connectedness between the different
neurons
similarly similarly i can never say that
word this these are depictions of this
is these these are the neurons of two
different scenarios this is the the
nerves of
of
animals that were in unstimulating
environments where they're not around
other other animals they're in a bear
cage and then this is this is the brain
of an animal that is in a stimulating
environment that is constantly being
challenged that is constantly looking at
stimulating new things and so the big
takeaway from this whole area of
research is you absolutely can change
your intelligence that your brain is
like a muscle the more you use it the
stronger it gets and that the best way
to grow it isn't to do things that are
easy for you that might help a little
bit but what really helps your brain is
when you struggle with things and it's
actually research shows that your brain
grows the most not when you get a
question right but when you get a
question wrong so at least for me this
is incredibly exciting because it lets
me know that when i'm going through
something and i'm facing those times of
maybe a little bit of adversity or a
little bit of frustration
i can i can i can feel good about the
fact that those are actually the times
that i am growing the most and this
isn't just something that i'm saying
nice words research tells us when you
get something wrong when you challenge
your brain when you review why you got
it wrong when you really process that
feedback that's when your brain grows
the most and that if you keep doing that
you're well on your way to having a
stronger more able and i guess you could
say smarter brain